not order
so if you see the new Ghostbuster
trailer yeah it did not look hot
yeah if that movie's any good they are
not marketing it very well
but who knows it might be okay yeah I
was almost thinking about not seeing it
but you know that pull feed guys have
bad trailers too good movies before so
would you be alright but hey guess who
has two thumbs and isn't seeing
Independence Day to this guy well done
it's like they always say just say no to
roland emmerich payday already we
remember what you said about the
Ghostbusters reboot how you were
thinking about not seeing it well I just
got back from the very effects you're
even thinking about not seeing it shows
that you're a misogynist what I'm sorry
I couldn't hear you over your
woman-hating wait that's what you're
upset about I'm upset that you were even
thinking about seeing it at all it
completely ruins what's perfect about
the original Ghostbusters look don't you
move you just whatever my thought what
do you care what you think so hostile
for something like Ghostbusters we
tweeted everybody about what you said
soon the world will expose you for the
Antichrist achoo
yeah go ahead I think the world is more
important things to worry about than
someone's opinion on ghostbusters
so what's trending today hmm another
terrorist attack huh more corruption in
our justice system double pass someone
thinking about not seeing the new
Ghostbusters movie someone's thinking of
not seeing the new Ghostbusters movie hi
Osamu do button head away the slime
ashaming Yahoo then I tried evening
tickled you must pardon me my breath an
emergency has befallen only menos on
today
you excuse me i reviewed to do i think
not what shut this off shut this whole
review off who the hell are you
this is so for justice Peck defender of
everything social justice II I will not
let you dislike the new Ghostbusters
movie you raging misogynist I'm a
misogynist because the trailer will die
crap the trailer was comic gold just
look at this poster booyah emphasis on
the boo laughter that's funny
anyone would find that funny unless of
course you're a misogynist
okay look I'm open to the idea of the
movie being good by the last belief well
if it isn't the Church of the heavenly
proton pack what a group of people who
love Ghostbusters so much they've
converted it into a religion oh my god
nobody shall go against the sacred wood
for the Senate pill I will one minute 17
dogs and cats living together mass
hysteria if you like anything in this
movie you're going against the sacred
texts shame shame shame shame shame
you're all crazy
he's locked himself inside good the let
us partake in the real yes
the real war let two internet extremes
partake in the ultimate battle yes the
ultimate battle I let the real mean
comment about you posted my disgust on a
message board you better look out I've
gotta master noon it's impossible to
talk about this movie without addressing
the controversy yeah did you know the
things you never talk about our religion
politics and ghostbusters before the
film even came out the people went
insane if you thought it would good you
were betraying the original if you
thought it looked bad you were a sexist
pig there was no in-between if you want
to go see it you were wrong
if you didn't want to go see it you were
still wrong well I did go and see a
shame and this is what I observed so
like before our three Ghostbusters are
scientists at a university for hunting
goes anorexic ones apparently then I get
one on video but the head of the college
is not pleased to see it on YouTube Oh
University does not want to be connected
with girls you don't want to be
connected with proof of the afterlife
well they're just icky and I don't like
them
you're fired in fact yes yes that's a
good choice on my part you need to look
Sabitha solder solder very good after
getting kicked out they moved their lab
above a Chinese restaurant ironically
plugging Papa John's Pizza and conduct
an interview for a new secretary boy I'm
Kevin I'll be a beefcake for the
remainder of evening I noticed your
glasses don't have any glass in them
yeah they kept getting daily so I just
took them out now this is both the
strength and the weakness of the film
that line about the glasses that was
pretty funny but it's immediately
followed by this oh it was loud huh it
was very loud yeah Kevin mistakes his
eyes for his ears
Kevin is too dumb I mean every
other second he'll say or do something
legitimately funny but then immediately
after he'll do something legitimately
unfunny oh sorry about that I forgot to
breathe again
am i thougt yet Christ David Homer
Simpson is looking at him like sure you
have earned my pity but it isn't just
that character the whole movie works
like this like when a subway worker
named patty comes in and says she saw a
ghost oh I saw a ghost this brings us to
the subway we're at the fitti artist
describes the ghost by drawing it on the
wall making life harder for it to
shuttle again that's kind of funny but
per the mathematical equation that for
some reason has to ride throughout this
film it's followed by something unfunny
do you see that see what that is that's
our ghost
it's our logo it's glad you know the
origin of that yeah it's really great
isn't it yeah it's a logo I don't know
if you know this but were the
Ghostbusters
ghosts ready to go sweaters that's what
that it oh okay
this leads us to our next ghost what you
need to realize are looking like mess
scooby-doo villains if they died in
Eddie Murphy's haunted mansion the
special effects were much better in the
first movie as it says in the sacred
script I believe it's magic yeah that's
true but here's the thing about the
original the effects are incredible and
the majority of them really hold up but
we can't forget that not only are they
silly looking but they too have their
fake moments remember the blue screen
stop-motion dogs some of those map
paintings aren't looking very real and
you can see through Stay Puft half the
time but we love them because they have
a distinct style their cartoony but
menacing these are kind of similar to
the ones in the Ghostbuster cartoon
which I guess you can see is either a
good thing or a bad thing I still like
the original effects better
still pretty visually interesting and
help give the film a different style so
it can stand on its own job but of
course nothing can have a film stand on
its own like shoving the original cast
down your throat Bill Murray and some of
the other casts all make cameos in this
yeah but that's to emphasize that they
give the blessing for the film yeah well
it comes off as training wheels the
movie doesn't need as if to say we're
isn't easy to accept all of this as you
are so maybe if we throw in the original
cast you love to remind you how much
it's not the original casting love it'll
go a lot easier but it's Bill Murray so
it's gotta be funny
right absolutely ah eternal abs who can
forget unbelievable lines like so this
video is a fake Hyup and that's it no
funny ways of pointing out how it's a
fake or funny reasons why he's a skeptic
the movies just like cut cut cut
gotta cut the scene but our scene isn't
it finished yet I'm sorry but looking at
Bill Murray's face is just depressing
people did you know him and samuel
l.jackson are the same age don't do
drugs kids son
so that those busters are finally in the
iconic jumpsuit tonight a minute what's
this what's what this one ugly stripe
yeah I feel like a Hot Wheels is gonna
race across my chest I don't know why
they made it look like you've been lasso
by orange and white Twizzlers just go
with it
this sucks right Abbi I'm right here
it's not me
whatever us bustin trackage pot hog feet
doctor zapping the new version of beats
dragon I mean not bad we get the next
big pointless cameo ones walking Prince
of Darkness a few years ago I would have
been more relevant you know even then it
would have been a cheap shot but God are
those clown fishes swimming around your
boo balloon get side uniforms and the
noise for the very first crazy y'all
you man you wouldn't say that if it
were on a man oh I'll knock it off you
act like anyone who doesn't like this
movie's a total sexist hypocrite man yes
okay maybe a few of us up oh Christ are
those the meninist we got offshore
relief to proclaim our outrage yeah
ladies can't beat ghostbusters nobody
were female ghostbusters yeah but not
the majority as a man this will not
stand
you know manliness isn't a real movement
right it's a blanket term were you just
so anxious to feel like victims you
joined the first group you google that
started complaining no yes yes but we're
still relevant they do not speak for us
oh you're from that Ghostbusters
religion you know the second film
doesn't count right oh you want the
Orthodox denomination they don't believe
in the second film either no that's not
true we believe it was made we believe
it said some good things but we do not
believe it's the word of the
Ghostbusters you are not truly authentic
Oh more authentic than the Ghostbusters
of latter-day saints
he's got a monkey your religion are you
- we only announced Volume one I need a
break while I cry for Humanity I'll be
right back
so Aaron shares why she's so uptight and
nervous to admit her beliefs since I was
a girl I saw ghosts every night at foot
of my bed but nobody believed me
everybody called me ghost girl so I had
to go to therapy wait a minute does this
scene end up going anywhere
well does the next scene end up going
anywhere well why don't you just cut to
that then you're gonna like it I don't
care just show it to me already
Oh more unfunny bummer I want proof of
this ghost you claim you caught you got
it whoa are you crazy showing him the
ghost would kill him I'm not doing it to
prove something to myself I'm not doing
it to show up this guy who hates us for
no reason I'm doing it because this is
the first movie since Garfield that Bill
Murray refuses to be funny yet the ghost
is released and killed Bill Murray when
who wait a minute they killed off Bill
Murray in this man oh this is
unacceptable this cannot man happen you
do realize that your precious
Ghostbusters 3 sequel never happen
because of this one guy right all right
killing so yeah the Ghostbusters just
murdered a man obviously the police drop
by take them to the mayor's office and
have them pay the price I believe what
you're doing and it's great work or they
face no consequences whatsoever really
hey man what a Ben Affleck's Batman up
in here as I was saying we know that
ghosts exist but we have to paint you as
frauds to not cause mass panic
isn't that like telling cops to stop
doing their jobs because people might be
intimidated by them what do you mean
might well pick your plot hole you can
either have the one that literally lets
you get away with murder
or you can have the one from
ghostbusters 2 where people stop
believing you for absolutely no reason
yeah anything but ghostbusters 2 mm-hmm
why does everyone always have that
reaction
Bill Murray baby talk is very
underappreciated meanwhile Erin is in a
hotel room looking over a notebook that
says who the bad guy is and wait about
why she suddenly in a hotel room in a
white robe away from everyone else
that's me again snip snip snip oh my god
why are you cutting so much you don't
understand we're terrified of our fans
we're
great to leave anything in this movie
why would you be afraid of your fan 20
not misogynist fair enough son and just
who is the bad guy who's been making
these machines enhancing paranormal
activity trying to destroy the world
some asshole we remember he has a name
it's just some asshole I guess I can't
act like Gozer had a lot of screen time
or a ton of character but there was at
least a backstory and some intimidation
about her this guy isn't intimidating or
funny he's just some asshole okay well
can we at least get a good reason why of
course Micah fellow you see no too
afraid of the fans to play to the fans
we're our own thing and if we ever
actually leave it in the bill will show
it to you
so so the villains ghost starts
possessing everyone until it finds a
proper home and Kip as he turns on his
machine to bring out all the ghosts of
the work so Aaron tries to get a ride
from a taxi driver played by force cameo
number 20 Danette you gotta give me a
ride there's ghosts everywhere oh that's
just a class 5 for roaming paper ok
we finally got a Ghostbuster cameo that
was funny because even if you did know
that was dan Aykroyd or what that line
is from how would a cab driver know such
an advanced term it happened we finally
got a cameo though yeah I think you are
forgetting our mathematical formula no
please the scene was fine it was money
don't ruin it are you sure it's a
knee-slapper no it is it you just think
it is mmm I know ain't afraid though of
no ghosts Wow yeah Blues Brothers 2000
ex ha ha this is the best Ghostbuster
cameo I've done since Casper get
out of here so Kevin takes control of
all the cops and soldiers trying to stop
him yeah I'm gonna force you to do a
swinging choreographed musical number Oh
scissors where are you oh I thought I
was doing my job too much you weren't
you were please don't make this thing
happen
all right I banish you to the end
credits oh I really thought this could
be the next Cuban song
we then come across easily the best
cameo in the entire movie saliva now I
know what you're thinking this is gonna
come across too child-friendly like in
the second movie or in the cartoon no
the best way I can describe Slimer and
this is whenever Neil Patrick Harris and
Harold and Kumar Go to White Castle that
Slimers performance he steals ecto-1
picks up all his ghost buddies and goes
on a bender even somehow manages to pick
up a female Slimer where the hell do
these things procreate I am so curious
help you not this they had an r-rating
he'd be doing lines of coke across her
belly the original creators always
described Slimer as the ghost of John
Belushi grand theft auto partying with
his friends and getting laid I buy that
so the Ghostbusters start busting the
ghosts with all the new gadgets and I
have to admit the action is kind of fun
this might be the one thing this film
actually does better than the original
and don't get me wrong the original
works fine but when you really look at
the action part of it what do I really
do they stand there and point a stick
when you get down to it that's not very
interesting in this one they do flips
and slides and punch ghosts and whip
them into somersaults what's the big
climax in the original they point the
sticks together oh my boy wall they run
on Harry Potter logic pointing is
amazing huh it looks like some people
are just more open-minded than others oh
by the way Vanessa are you down for
watching the Jim movie tonight
yeah there's little to do with the
original it just didn't look very good
well I can respect your opinion well
that's what I thought oh the Ghostbuster
trailer misogynist the villain turns
into a giant version of their logo
because this movie that's trying to be
its own thing is also ending with a
giant white cartoon blob perhaps it's
symbolic of the fanbase trying to
destroy itself
don't make me protest at your funeral so
after he turns into this giant monster
he walks away yeah he says he's going to
destroy them but he just kind of veers
up somewhere
maybe he's off to tell Godzilla he
should smash buildings on screen but
they shoot the ghosts in the crotch
because if it worked in these nineties
films clearly it should work here let me
figure out how to suck all the ghosts
back in to the portal but unfortunately
Evie get sucked into Aaron however goes
an effort hey you've got white hair now
yeah so do I suppose this will be
unexplained in pointless like the
villains backstory or your ghost girl
thing while logos on a subway wall or
how this is all gonna probably be
covered up like in the transformer
movies but as I've learned with
franchises that have a snot ball that
apparently have an afterlife and a miss
pac-man girlfriends can't read too much
into it
and I was Ernie Hudson
genius awful I still don't get it how
did everyone become so hostile over
something obviously not worth the effort
I did it
Oh black willy wonka you're responsible
for all of this oh yes I've used the
Internet to consume their lives
what used to be a fun pastime has now
turned into a cul-de-sac of rage where
people used to share their opinions
now they forced them down your throats
in fact I just hijacked Facebook so that
instead of the like button there will be
a force button making sure nobody can
have an opinion of their own where you
see media was once used to enhance your
life now it's replaced it look like
Willy Wonka why you see people need to
learn the power of their choices critic
so by turning them into whiny little
babies maybe they'll learn
we won't well every once in a while a
symbol comes along to remind everyone of
how awful they can be Ghostbusters is
that symbol no one isn't sometimes the
universe just needs to hate itself you
have no reason for doing any of this do
you nope sometimes it's fun to be an
asshole for no reason
see everyone it isn't you it's the
internet it's consuming your lives
making you paranoid and stupid and this
movie is at the heart of it he's right
don't bust their Chicago division blade
here it doesn't matter whether you like
or hate the film what matters is that
it's your opinion and it wasn't for
stunning
because a Ghostbuster doesn't hate a
Ghostbuster doesn't discriminate
Ghostbuster stands for peace and freedom
the freedom to think what you want to
think love for your fellow fan or hatred
it's your choice
fanbase is pulsing with entitlement it's
gonna take a tremendous amount of
positive energy to snap them out of it
you know I just can't believe things
have gotten so bad in fan bases that
there's no way back I mean I know we're
geeky we obsess over little things and
we probably get too invested but we've
gone from being bullied all our lives to
being bullies ourselves I love
Ghostbusters I love the franchise I love
the toys I love the cartoons I even kind
of have a soft spot for the second movie
enough to quote it in a satire remember
when talking about those Buster's used
to be funny I just wish I could enjoy
being a Ghostbuster fan again not
ashamed
we need something everybody can get
behind we need
assemble something that appeals to the
Ghostbuster fan in all of us something
that was new from familiar something
good something decent something pure
you
let's raise the love to the Internet
Oh card you a more level-headed yeah
enough for me to question why I'm still
dry oh the ecto cooler has so much sugar
in it that the liquid fades very quickly
okay so now that we're all little calmed
down
I'm ready to tell you my real opinion
about the new Ghostbusters movie I
thought the movie was average it's not
great it's not awful it's just average
but that doesn't fit into one of our
sides yeah you can do that you can still
believe in equal rights and think this
movie sucks you can still love the
original and think this one is great by
God you can have such a variety of
different thoughts that you might
actually be considered a unique human
being I've accepted that nothing can
ever recreate the original it's an
anomaly of all the right things in all
the right places at all the right time
it's childish but a dolt stupid but
intelligent by all definitions it
shouldn't have worked and yet it worked
perfectly
it really is lightening that will never
strike again hell even the original
people tried to recreate it and it
didn't work it got a few laughs but
everybody acknowledges it couldn't
capture the magic of the first the
closest we got is the game and even then
that had to repeat a lot of stuff and
let's face it it wouldn't have worked as
well if we saw them at the real age I
didn't want to see ghostbusters 3 for me
it's asking for another Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull or blue Brothers 2000 if
we're gonna get something new that's
ghostbusters I do want it to be
different and the different stuff is
when I think it shines the most you know
those shows movies and comics where
there's like a million parallel
universes this just feels like all those
parallel universes not a replacement
just a different version the dark knight
films don't erase out the original
Batman The Rise of the Planet of the
Apes films don't destroy the style and
genius of the original does it all work
hell no do I hate that every funny joke
is followed by an unfunny joke
definitely if you're going to say though
that this movie stole your
childhood you never had a childhood
we're stealing yeah must have been a lot
of great things in that life for a movie
to take it away from you
but it's not hard to see somebody hating
this bill there are a lot of unfunny
scenes and awkward moments and yeah it
doesn't really need to exist but I can
also see how someone can enjoy it the
performers are great there are some
really funny jokes and it can be really
creative for me I like it the most when
it's doing its own thing and it doesn't
need to call back to the original but
not everybody's gonna see it that way
and that's fine Ghostbusters is gonna be
something unique and different to
everybody because everybody has their
own unique experience to it so if you
want to go see it go see it if you don't
want to go see it don't go see it as
long as your decision is yours and
you're not bullied by anybody into doing
something you don't want to do or think
what you don't want to think I suppose
some of those lines really weren't that
amusing Oh some of those gadgets we're
pretty badass can we at least all agree
that ecto cooler is amazing yes yes oh
no you don't yeah you may have gotten
everyone else to speak their minds but
we're keeping ours nice and close yeah I
don't give up hello oh hi hold on uh let
me put you on videophone hi everyone I
was wondering if you saw the new
Ghostbusters yet oh oh yes we have
little girl what did you guys think I
thought it was great I liked the part
where they bust the balloon ghosts punch
the ghost in the face and then they play
the song I dance so much of that song
all my friends are so excited to dress
up this Halloween in fact we started
wearing our costumes in a few places
already even some kids in the hospital
we're really excited to see them
so I really liked it what did you all
think you know what it doesn't really
matter what we think yeah as long as you
liked it okay I showed her yeah you
showed her who's boss why don't we go
complain about real I'm the
Nostalgia Critic with the Chicago
ghostbusters saying ghostbusters will
never die as long as you keep sharing
the law
so celebrate whichever version you love
fest and remember both of you makes me
feel good
you
it's our logo did you glad you know the
origin of that yeah it's really great
isn't it yeah it's a logo
coming next week it's the live-action
Adventures of Teddy Ruxpin set your
nightmares - hahahaha but you can see it
now under vessels ad free early access
just three dollars a month to see tons
of people's videos early as well as a
bunch of other extra features check it
out and get the early scoop hey Doug
Walker here doing the charity shout out
this week we are doing homes for our
troops this is a privately funded
nonprofit organization that builds
mortgage free specially adapted homes
nationwide for severely injured veterans
post 9-11 to enable them to rebuild
their lives most of these veterans have
sustained injuries including multiple
limb amputations partial and full
paralysis or severe traumatic brain
injury these homes restore some of the
freedom and independence our veterans
sacrifice while defending our country
and enable them to focus on their family
recovery and rebuilding their lives
nearly 90 cents of every dollar has gone
directly to the veterans in this program
despite their life-altering injuries
many of these veterans have embarked on
new careers completed their college
degrees or started families many have
embraced their roles as motivational
speakers sharing their messages of
preserving through tragedy with groups
of classrooms around the country others
take to a national platform to promote
awareness of veteran suicide
homelessness and post-traumatic stress
disorder their incredible stories are
the driving force for this charity and
you can hear so many of them not only on
their website but on their YouTube page
as well definitely show how much you
care about these men and women who have
sacrificed so much for this
give some back to those who have given
so much
you